you're nominated for homecoming
congratulations thank you somewhere The
Hollywood Reporter's calling you a
breakout star all of this is happening
right now how does that feel to get that
Golden Globe not aa weird and crazy at
the same time you know it's just it's
just an incredible thing to know that
people are watching your work and people
are appreciating your work so if
anything I'm just I'm just glad for that
maybe a day
I see you later Jody see you Walter I
mean I'm probably the luckiest like 25
year old on the planet at this you know
to be able to go from Barry Jenkins in
Beale Street to Samish million
homecoming but Barry's I mean just a
phenomenal filmmaker has an incredible
eye for storytelling
probably amongst some of the most you
know passionate and patient directors
I've ever worked with it I love you you
know that I don't and I understand what
you're going through because I'm with
you
are you picking up things being on set
with these directors knowing that it
might not always be this way yeah yeah
and you know I have directorial
aspirations as well do ya of course and
to be able to just pick up jams from
some of the best in the business I like
that couldn't be more fortunate what do
you think an Oscar nomination would mean
for this film any recognition
this film was garnered it just means the
world and and if if these nominations
mean that folks are gonna get out and
and see the film and tell other people
to see the film and I'm all for it